si le choc considérable parce qu'ils
voient cet immeuble détruit et puis on
pense de suite à ses locataires
après le choc et l'inquiétude des
premières heures les victimes viennent
ici chercher de l'aide et surtout des
informations juriste assureurs
psychologue
cette association d'aidé aux victimes
permet d'y voir plus clair solution
durable de relogement constitution de
partie civile pour suivre au plus près
l'information judiciaire ou encore
conseils dans les procédures
d'indemnisation
on va essayer de traiter les sujets qui
nous sont propres c'est à dire les
assurances pour les biens matériels
les assurances oscille concernant les
problèmes autres que ceux du matériel et
puis surtout essayer de faire un
collectif de manière à ce que les gens
n'aillent pas dans plusieurs endroits
alors que là on est tous concernés par
le même la même explosion
l'objectif de cette permanence à c'était
de faire en sorte que ces victimes ne se
sentent pas abandonner trop longtemps et
d'avoir un interlocuteur unique
privilégiés qui puisse les accompagner
dans leurs démarches les informer et les
orienter les guider
depuis l'explosion la ville de dijon a
pris un arrêté d'interdiction d'habiter
concrètement pascal descoings tout comme
les habitants de quatre bâtiments
voisins ne peuvent plus jusqu'à nouvel
ordre rentrer chez eux
du côté des commerces pas de réouverture
envisagé pour le salon de toilettage le
restaurant asiatique lui ne devrait pas
rouvrir avant deux mois
volley et vitres cassées le cabinet
d'architectes situé juste à côté du
sinistre a paradoxalement subi peu de
dégâts l'équipe a cessé le travail d'une
journée mais pour les gérants cette
explosion a eu d'autres effets nous
laissera des traces peut-être écologique
pour nos soins qui ne sont pas vraiment
exprimé par l'ensemble des
des salariés notre agence d'architecturé
par nous mêmes par les gérants de la
société
nous ne sommes pas vraiment exprimé à ce
sujet mais je pense que ça laissera des
traces au c'est sûr c'est certain
aujourd'hui seuls les habitants du 15
rue palio ont été autorisés à pénétrer
dans ce qui reste de leur logement
une brève visite où ils ont pu récupérer
quelques affaires